yeah the emergency vet Tony's been
outstanding
everybody is coming yes all right yeah
emergency evacuation announcement we'll
take that as recognize yeah yeah
apologies for absence we've received
apologies in office from councillor
Cooper and counselor Alton are there any
substitute members none non members
attending good evening Council of
Western welcome minutes of the meeting
held on the 17th of April is about
maintained so are they afraid I to the
five to receive declarations of any
first are there any
item six the external auditor reports
updates and we are to consider the
report of the assistant director
democratic services updating members on
the progress and respective external
audit recommendations arising from final
audit report for the year ending 30
fester March 2017 and the certification
of claims have been terms only report
for 2016-17 I'm going kept me on the
principal auditor this report provides
updates on all the recommendations from
a particular thing is related to
Department report on the certification
of claims returned recommendations from
the report the report has now been
implemented in full and working of
course with applications for the second
any questions so the recommendation is
it is proposed the committee resolves
the updates provided in the one entry
sheet in respectively external auditors
second named recommendations been ot7
that is the internal audit annual report
frankly bubbling - you know my name is
my important on the impacted teeth would
executive decree watcher council
under a three-year contract my day job
is with bathroom counselor on the hill
here asthma counselor
okay thank you refer memphis 2007 okay
but this my aunt report is to provide an
opinion on the council's arrangements
with governance risk management and
internal control for 2017-18 my opinion
for 1719 is that adequate assurance and
the council's arrangements for risk
management internal control and
governors-general for the proper
practice fundamentally sound there was
some debate at the uncool own meeting
last week Esther would use adequate yes
is that were generally used by in
certain audiences it's you can take it
to be satisfactory it's it's it's
basically this is to say on the
practices or cell we tend to use
etiquette boards and I missed its
engineering term we tend to use you
might not agree prefer to a school
report we must they can do better but
generally it's okay it's fine
so basically my opinions is basically
arrangements are called proper practice
and fundamentally sound we're an issue
have been identified internal auditors
many suitable recommendations and be put
up on those as part of the best practice
menu does not imply that internal order
is reviewed already all risks relate to
the council and we can't look at all
where isn't it in any one year so
basically there's a plan of audit work
that we usually am pushing place at
start of the year so how do I arrived at
my opinion pretty pretty free to be we
put together a plan of work for start
that year which we bring to the Audit
Committee and that's their proven signed
up it outlines all the work we've done
on the tank in 1718 and all the audience
we're going to do agree to audio we
actually provide an assurance rating and
that's how I actually get to my any
opinion so I prefer members to head upon
7.6
pants on provides a list of all units
we've completed in the air
and as you will see we've completed at a
large number all across a wide spread
spectrum of council activities from an
audit team that's generally consisted of
one number of start by each in we've
completed a lot of work in 1719 and that
should be applauded as I said out the
point to make is that we can't look at
every year everything in one year and we
try to cover if in Union in a three-year
cycle if I can just flick over the base
appendix to this is on 79 this provides
an executive summary of all the evidence
we've completed since January 2019 for
last hungry for toward community there
are a couple of our recently missing
from appendix 2 we haven't provided
information for debtors and for Kidman
because at that time we went through two
Freedman
we haven't basic confuse those who
sacrifice summary so there are a couple
missing from pending to also I think we
touched on the fact that we had just
proof these thoughts and work on a
couple of contracts for leisure and
stream scene we have started the work
that this work is now been suspended as
we've concentrate million housing
benefit subsidy and as I stated cookies
laudably completely 1718 we actually
provide an assurance rating it's very
good and equip are limited for 1719 for
audit reviews receiver limited assurance
rating and ten included or adequate
rating so okay so how about some
assurance we provide explain to an audit
how reliable is
is it any good so the while work is
actually governed by the public sector
into the community engines and we are
required to undergo an external quality
assessment every five years these are 30
undertaken in January 2018 and then
cocktail with reporters provided
appendix 5 the external assessment
resources which is failure to ensure the
felonies like keeping that main please
looking to make sure that the reason
faded into each other with governments
as the area were checking to make sure
that were covering the risk the risk is
a failure to provide government's the
risk is we don't provide consistent
value for money and that's the risk that
we remove all within the start of the
movie a little bit we're not saying
there is failure basically it's the risk
we are auditing again so what we look
for is two controls in place to prevent
that failure so it's just a description
for risk
basically said this is or is and then
we're going to actually this is walking
to to music oh that [ __ ] this is the
controls available so we look at all the
controls that prevent that risk when
editing in the first place that's how we
only undertake imodium okay thank you
okay sorry
and section nine resource implications
not in public once there's a comment
everyone makeup even house another Mabel
third-party turn would resource is
considered sufficient at present at the
time producing report we just run them
at burn campaign and have a plaintiff
and you senior or deserve but at the
time of Beijing going and checking
references and a green and he decided
not to take up the post so we now can
see casinos so something that subsequent
and send it down so we have now really
in the attic a moment it's the a doubt
now it's going through a Chianti
speaking only a few months before they
Sarah it's not really sufficient at
present ask a question that well why is
it sir and do we know the reason why I
took another job or was it he had a
temporary contract with watershed
council and they decided to make him
permanently is an imitation world you
know
before each other and the job said
basically the audit resources a
continuing problem I faced at Buzz's
little more time okay it's how you do it
to music like that so there's a number
of avenues and options you can actually
find a resource it if it gets to that
stage where you can't find a suitable
candidate you can actually buy that
resources from an arm that counts in
practice but there is a significant
course 9.2 we still got a problem there
but a little bit yes it's the same thing
the regional news yes
is there anything being done to again we
buy in ICT forty days and we also rely
on third-party assessments because
there's a health tech undertaking by
third party which confirms up code of
connectivity so you should be relying on
third party assurance in relation to IT
work so we're not really looking for
anybody to know there's sufficient
assurance this one third parties in that
area cancel my just a couple of
questions for you like all we played
some point to user IC t security it's
safe a similar rules we came in at the
last meeting is is there any changes to
that we still seem to be have potential
vulnerabilities ICT health check still
seems to be under ye I'm just wondering
how fast it's going over if it's an
ongoing process which will continue
until now they'll secure substitutes and
enough they clicking the health check
has to be completed
reporters who put back
it has been worked on by errant parity
staff we are expecting to still see
issues relating to the unsupported
service but there is a plan in place to
get those sorted out by the end of the
summer the party member staff to
speaking today she felt they've had been
anything significant below we would have
been made aware of that immediately and
she's not anticipating anything that we
weren't aware of I haven't seen the fine
details of it I was hoping to go far
away today
so at the next meeting we should ever we
shouldn't know it should be different
totally situated like you're much more
on the bait and we should be looking to
some things of getting towards the prize
winning the public safety Network okay
thank you Porter how do you finish your
presentation of Yuriko it started
service just about any questions on that
are there any other questions okay
Thank You chairman questions actually
stuck with just leaking off from what
you just said in your next report we
will be looking at actually do actually
have a date stated on their bit
migration will be complete is that now
I'm not going to happen so in migration
of the the IDC
ICT I'm not sure the the fine their
final date for migrations to clap it's a
miracle
maybe to my pin would come to the next
realtor are okay I'll bring that my
thing but I'll just bring down as you
don't mention it at seven point three in
motion
a champion that you know that being
identified from William Gustav this is
my new post is it an anything post
who is it actually it's not momentum
placement the risk
yeah it's not it's not a substantial
price in its own right in that as a GG
didn't fight in existence so on and so
you see we wanna change got this and you
feel good well it's not someone it sits
on the leadership team but it's and
someone that substance suitable
seniority in the organization together
so it's 9/32 to you well essentially yes
she's a few bits within their finance
and finance to me so yeah I think is
there extra remuneration be in paying
for that
I don't know same time you save up to
buy praise your name you should do that
pipe I have got quite a few questions if
you bear with it
supportive environments will Paris
it's the only recommendation category
where you give a number of items in s
there one of the things that has
actually been brought to my attention
recently is the fact of some people some
references actually advertising
five-star rating of Rochford canceled on
there there's and it's actually one it's
actually being done about that okay in
relation to those matters members of
public can report that there's obviously
an online that it doesn't agree that
they can actually report that issue to
the council and then the council will
actually come to take you to see the
focused action so there is a mechanism
for a fourth nice so it's not something
that we would continue check for whether
those low ratings a New England fly with
the application or something the council
does surely though someone let's say for
instance in this particular case get to
one star yeah you've been willing to
check that they've actually downgraded
to notice in their window you will do
that yes is anyone do that
it's partly the process whereby they may
attends they can review they were then
check that freitas they'll be put in the
window off of you because they can go
back in something could inspect their
for instance if they should be done yet
easy be done I would have to check
consider that's the case can you come
back to to life yes just jump in there I
was in at a cafe in Rockville with the
other day and their certificate to thank
you 2014 so I think especially done at
least every three years
can I just come back tonight some
establishments have found more of them
there's a risk rating just depends
actually on how often a premises is
inspected so to restrain someone
reviewed every year some three years
where the council applies the risk
rating
- II stopped for purposes that meant
determinants actually inspection for
thing was four years ago
where's but it's up about and I on the
premises and I can tell you which is due
for inspection if you love the question
out and take that back up to the
appropriate team and see let's do for
inspection last - yes yeah if you give
me a name probing system you can take
that back I'll tell you up is amazing
it's just for the new members and maybe
some forgotten recommendation category C
SML are they place what do I stand for
sorry significant question and I'm good
dancer so I 7.14 going to risk a news
we've got to calm down one against
they're fighting to ensure the
contractors partners or company wooden
or with the council and effective
policies and procedures to meet pay off
the safety advance does that look good
Greendale I think over have signed up to
council standards for health and safety
so there doesn't look things that in
that moderate poverty is we were looking
in the contract procedures rather than
specific contracts okay
moving a 17-7 14% sorry 719 we've all
recently experienced consultation with
the plane that is mentioned there is on
the consultation and engagement is about
the websites and the engagement that we
had with the with the community one of
the regular complaints that we have all
experienced is the difficulty of finding
things on the website can this be noted
and made much much easier to root access
on future consultations ok I have
actually had a few residents who
actually have said to me even after I've
iPod directing them to the right page to
say that we could we have spent so much
time trying to find it we gave up so
that's not helping to get a good feel of
what the actual public feeling in
regards to consultation the other thing
is the drop in the bins very much
appreciated the Planning Department
officers being here
but the information that they had with
them was extremely sparse and in some
cases incorrect they had in the one that
I went to a third object very short they
had been like a lot of the actual
proposed sites were not actually on the
map and it was actually a consultation
for areas that were on the new area
plane there was a bit mystifying can I
just ask the question that
concerns rights at the time with 728
when it comes to the air quality
management the top top item we've got in
there come up and talk to the air
quality monitoring and make the
statement publicly available on the
website or in the executive summary to
the annual air quality of status report
can I request there that we actually
replace the or we end I think that would
be in the interest of transparency is
that possible
yes possible request on to the services
yep
thank you he don't make no question one
way I don't like in cases others I want
to see obsidian 7:30
like the passion vacuum contact with
make the council's banker to determine
why there's an average of five six days
and receiving value projector emitted
etc have you had any sports I had a
response the bank processes as soon as
they get to the problem seems to be busy
present company with the education
company new people to you to claim
confession checks from deposit at the
bank
yeah so I need someone who sorry it just
hit me from all your picking we go we
don't tell the stuff over to the bank we
have it selected by this you can do that
if you understand get me to the others
yes yep okay they're not on this
7:38
I was a little bit concerned that's why
my happiest thoughts about reporting
fraud committee there is a
recommendation there that it actually
that fraud should be commits should be
reporting to the committee I distinctly
remember about a year ago that this
matter appeared in some of the documents
that we had then I haven't had time to
look up the minutes but I did point out
at the time that if there was any fraud
that was proven within the council that
we as a as a committee should be a
tolerant straight way this we would be
the link to the public and they would be
asking us I think it just makes sense
and I'm a little bit concerned that it
appears as though that has been
completely lost and it's been
recommended again the second paragraph
in many observations refers to the
anti-fog encryption policy which is a
bit out of date no reference to getting
internal audit and the committee
involved in that one within the audience
chatter though that was available who
would have made the project would advise
the Audit Committee
should there be any cases at all but two
haven't been that apartment all the
revenues benefits and there hasn't been
anything were aware of so Kathleen that
easy implies yes okay
yeah the process we do have two reports
a committee actual fraud there's not
been any fraud else - jim says present
beds where it's just like the payments
where we look at it and recovery
airplane
for music bass today or to need to be
some torch we essentially say there's
been a change circumstances is to happen
in that day and we apply at the Ministry
of penalties and then basically recovery
hoping that's that's the five sects
possible a plethora conservative council
tax cats a group O two completely
separate questions the rest factors are
then covered by these sort of insurance
policies at all it's not not feasible in
a local government sort of situation
there's the several options in terms of
mitigating the risk you can insure you
can basically accept the risk and do
nothing about it so in some places where
the only option is to be sure you
probably would
what sort of a percentage of the items
are covered like I might have had to
have antennae with specific areas but
there are options you can choose to to
frankly machine that risk in certain
circumstances yes right okay thank you
my other question was item seven seven
point three so they mentioned about fire
alarm testing
I was just going to say that the
building where I work they carry out the
fire alarm test on a Friday morning but
I've never present on the Friday morning
so I never hear the alarm oh and like
means that one's fine and there might be
better to have a test ultimately maybe
Mondays to Fridays or if you've got a
person that only works part-time they
might never hear that alarms as I think
part of the think about letting out a
regular time is that people who do the
check unless you have to remember to do
it on that time encourages them as well
it has been implemented now as he says a
comment of what you say but it is
possible is partner in getting into his
or discipline to make sure has been done
okay thank you
follow-up to that we should have one I
know counsel made recently the
precipitous is in the rope should be a
little innocent yeah okay we kind of
decided I think it's pretty obvious when
a fire alarm goes off of these
photograph I mean it seems an obvious
thing to sahi burning well let's go
inside chair was that's up in on the
council two years I've never ever hear
or all DC office he's been in there when
there's been a fire alarm and you're
quite right we all know what firing
armies and what it sounds like but do we
know if it's a taste
can we get out on this bit we've always
had the safety thing get down those
stairs can we do it you've never ever
had it tested
we've never been in the chamber when
we've had a lot of people in the chamber
where there could be a lot of easily
yeah we have had fun in out of for
counseling husband a few years ago chair
so I'm not have been here months I've
been here two years
yeah but it was a very pleasant evening
I can remember any thoughts you need for
members as well
stuff perhaps that's one thing though
that with having you did a regular time
when underlying the fact that if it's
not at that regular time it must be a
far different there might be a scientist
at Willamette wrong but if you start
varying when the testing arms come
people aren't gonna know it's gonna
confuse things
what could just have to - but what week
it's one day another week it's another
day perhaps you could take this baton
and have a things that the fire alarms
okay you're right I'm going to say they
are generally done the same time every
week so everyone knows and text outsider
that goes off it's really the best way
to suggest that I should know at the
same time salad cancer sure did did you
ask your question notice I nothing we
should have members should have we only
have member meetings there should be
counsel ahoy thank you shouldn't be
stood on coffee can say it uses right
some of my questions that we're going to
the game
so Phil there be answered hey you just
seven quick one one lady has been
finding Phillip Rogers but I just use
this one this honest these notes
elsewhere
we're selling God is I suppose the first
question is if it has an impact on the
subsidy claiming what what level of
exposure I'll be open to on that ie how
much main that affects the subsidy
played by how much money and also when
I'm sorry I couldn't game up on my
computer but notice on your hair send
them out or someone has sent them out
that we've had the latest and financial
information through and I think from
memory and I'll have to go in front of
me but agreed it I'm not sure it's
slipping back into the rent of again the
collection five housing around house it
may still be is an ongoing problem still
if we're still having a backlog to deal
with the reports that we're after the
backlog but then it seemed to be
slipping into the reading hand and
placed one around but very lives in
there as well and it's relating to the
same issue around the clock yeah so
you're right and it's still read in
surprise it we're still lower than the
beginning of the year and there was a
quite significant backlog at the start
of the air but we have made progress and
catching up so over the year we are
still behind the time which way we
wanted to be but we have my pros in
terms time catching up so we are in we
are improving we are on the right and
path when that policy was still slightly
below where we would like to be at this
time but I think the automatron
assayer's was known through 17 18 - 18
19 we still have a backlog is that still
was for the end of year for 17 18 so we
haven't reported on 1899
time said yes I was not talk to you yeah
and have we got any idea of how much
this might cost us at the moment it says
it could have an impact horse
particularly impact high monetary terms
well we haven't finalized the housing
benefit subsidy playing at this moment
or it's still being audited so that will
subsequently before it back to what it
committee as later date once we've
finished their testing so I can't put a
quantifiable value at this time but that
will be reported to a subsequent audit
committee once that's one of the claims
being audited yeah and as a further
follow-up to that we're in the final
paragraph here refers to fact
overpayments babies are actively insured
which we would expect bearable what sort
of pursuit are we talked about we talked
about full tax and bay leaves or are we
actually going in actively to help
people to pay because these could be
assessed potentially might have made
some people not just concerned it yeah
this may not be recoverable in in
reality I think we're trying to get a
more sensible views to what is
recoverable that's really clearly not
going to be plentiful a certain ones we
can't go after this a fault for example
never significant over the payments the
result of orcas identified by the DWP we
don't go involved in the prosecution of
those and there are mandatory maximums
that you can recover from ongoing
benefit which would make some this last
number will be a mortgage but they are
the thing we're very Kate Trotter
interesting in pursuing what they go for
and we do use all the appointment
afternoon including corpus but even now
so the cost of taking a small tech
support was almost double it so there's
multiple takes of chasing my good after
that something we would always seek to
even cover the payment so we would
always identified okay would always seek
to recover it busy say if someone is not
compliant with that request - for the
overpayment and then it obviously it's
done on a risk assessed biases of where
it's then cost-effective to proceed the
debt or not and what would happen to
that village they don't receive any
house when many people didn't come out
like a certainty is that there was a
problem there was a something which we
denied it for which meant as a result of
pharoah identifying something at many
many people were overpaid as I read this
but I'm just concerned about how we are
always been affected there are many
people who have overpayments who are
still ongoing benefits gets us there in
cycles they would not be no effective
writer kind of anything really that one
nothing there ones what we've already
been almost correspond to people oh no
there's been almost again council
sparing no it's just stretchy
any other questions
just one final one for mayonnaise is
only this one because I think only
comments I hadn't questions I haven't
been asked and answered
Oh page seven point three five point two
talking about this case you identify
things instead for example the temple
forward maybe preventive in let's attack
speed damage of the truth by improving
with checking a staff because they are
employed a little bit concerning because
they think would be checked surely with
references and DBS anyway so what other
checks are we talking about no this is
you saying Greek we do anything those
checks
so we are undertaking your scattering
okay it's just the way it was wait read
I thought it improve your attending of
staff it is actually his peace beamed up
it's just to work with you says the way
it's worth it is actually just saying
you overall fraud arrangements are in
prayer through undertaking this series
of checks this includes checking staff
sir basically it's saying this this is
the book standard fraud slaves but you
can improve this by doing a number of
thing it is being done that long right
then it's just essentially refusing
yes thinking about it done for all when
you start for is it just those in
finance when you start going through
check or preferences yes I have some
more about this reference yeah for
Samsung did at bps joke say basically
you do check of past criminal acts
irrigation was right no all right thank
you
so no further questions actually seven
then is that the Commission resolves
that the chief they're all direct tips
opinion on the overall adequacy and
effectiveness of the council systems of
government mismanagement an internal
control V no item eight is the annual
government statements to 1718 and I'm
the acting section one five one observed
District Council's I'm spending
permitted County Council under the
current arrangements and yes part of
that role enough obviously I have them
perform in terms of the internal
governance arrangements as well so I
think members will be aware that partly
helps market regulations we are required
to use an annual government statement
each year which should be presented to
members for their consideration the
purpose of the annual government
statement is to identify the procedures
that the house undertakes to ensure is
an effective system of internal
governance and control in place upon
which you can place place your assurance
local authorities have a sort of strips
and guidelines to adhere to which are
set out in this merciless framework
delivery moving up good governance in
local governments your committee is
asked to review
in a statement which is intended to
report and to recommend to these leader
and Managing Director that it's approved
as part of the accounts which are due to
be published next week as I've said the
younger government statement has been
appended to the report and it basically
sets out the how the statements be
repaired and the seven principles I just
mentioned all have evidence and
assurance which of each system which
provide the assurance that the council
has adequate procedures in place to meet
each of the seven government's
principles part of the assurances that
heavenly plates on the internal audit
recommendations so the the previous
report we had from Jim Mike
in terms of internal audit report it's
one of the main sources of assurance we
use the Daniel government statement but
it's not the only one we have a number
of other sources of assurance which
include the policies and procedures of
transparent place and also service
assurance statement each individually
that assistant director has completed to
give a view of the controls with their
names visual areas so you set out within
the under government statement is that
the council does have adequate assurance
and procedures in place to deal with a
final internal governance and therefore
we are asking that you would agree that
the owner elements a
is agrees and conform heartedly and your
counts are 17 18 so I'm not the
placements go into detail because I
think it's reasonably self-explanatory
in terms of their the detail sitting
behind it obviously if there's any
specific question as members wish to ask
we'll do our best
thank you are there any questions Carrie
first place be small thank you 8.6
second line and this is really sensitive
is rockford based off and use of other
available information to stop selling
home code on them from local service
provider okay okay proof ready is just
something which also don't care that I'm
not always if I've seen it metal raise
it eight point seven this is just look
around training and I did sounds
protectively game we have your members
of developers license you know pills
committees undertake mandatory training
is appropriate this part of them
counselor mrs. cristinita territory
members of licensing do not undergo
mandatory training members of licensing
who want to sell in the subcommittee
undergo mandatory training that was
changed this year so that's actually in
the is recording the training footage
but if you've all got that so it's
slightly different user licensing and
not beyond North undertaking that
mandatory training but if you wish to
sit on the subcommittee you have to have
undertake of the mandatory training okay
well yeah I don't know I'll take the
word for it that's why they send their
yes
very nice that was tracked by the
standard School Committee issue yeah the
plastic subcommittees I suppose them on
that apron - I'm just writing the same
that says that every phrase earlier
valid we made about really engagement
particular and the budgetary order I
think with we're mentioning it I don't
think it was with mentioning and not
saying if it's the engagements got
obeyed I don't know I think he was
disciplined in what I was disappointing
if we did an honest report so it would
be nice to have more engagement from
members of the public so the second
paragraph on page eight quit nine could
say something about the new local plan
but in we always think it could be done
better but when I guess asparagus here
he chairs that the feelings behind and I
think it was a lot better than the first
local plan anyway so I'm not gonna
criticize that it was just really around
but I don't know what you can do you
can't direct people out sorry
I mean if um knocked on their door nine
out of ten probably saying yeah not
really very interested I know enough
about it and I'm coming I don't know I
don't know if you can say it's
disappointing if you put something out
there and people choose not to to pursue
it I mean the information was available
we did we delivered a leaflet in regard
to some to every house in the in the
district if people don't want to respond
to that I mean what you say it's
disappointing or
lack of you know apathy or whatever but
I don't quite know what else you're
supposed to do to encourage people to to
respond to you we've gone in and
contacted every household in the
district but we can't force them to
respond to us yeah exactly how much I
was actually more referring to the
budget one I wasn't referring aware
though I think you've done a lot more
than what's on the first on but let's
say I think I think it's the same thing
though is you cannot force people to
become involved you can only put the
tools in their hands if they choose not
to use them
that is the case with most things that
you can put up posters you can as you
say knock on doors but it's a decision
people make to get engaged to engage or
not how many yeah I think in all aspects
where the council has tried to you know
get involved more and then is there and
once you've registered who comes out
time and time again but I mean I'll be
honest I would think knowing my own Road
most of them if they won't know anything
they see me walking down and I said what
kind of it is and that's about it
seriously difficult love is we are
trying to engage
I think the point I was trying to raise
on that earlier on was that in the
particular case that we had the you know
play issue the website was an issue and
I think we're all aware of that being
the case because as you to try and find
the response forms in the website was
for torturous exercise exercise it could
do with being much much much more
straightforward in the future I was
sorry
how does a great see if I'm also paucity
of the knobs on them on page eight point
one two is regarding so the
so check yourself I see local
authorities it's not necessary correct
you can see it's just furthering a
question ask for counsel of the
imaginative Managing Director which was
territories from the state so I thought
I'd ask you here as well the there was a
first paragraph 9.12 it refers to a
grant of nine hundred thousand pounds
awarded to in the actual grant
application that was made which was made
by Thoreau as effectively the legal
authority in the grouping the the
application detailed monies which were
for money already spent on things such
as this strategic housing management
which is obviously a joint thing which
we've also spent money on so my question
has always been and will be again today
can we please see how much of that money
we get because that shouldn't surely go
back dirty to us and our planning policy
budget as a recovery but that's
specifically in the ground it would say
there's recovery and accordant even the
fingers clever but it would meet time
but you know it was a significant number
of hundreds of thousands couple of
hundred thousand yeah I agree with what
you've said as far as I'm aware and I
haven't had an update on this and very
recently there hasn't been a firm
allocation of monies how the monies will
be shared between the authorities and in
essence the majority of the money is for
joint work so so it's not a case of it
being divvied up between all the
authorities the big phrase it's to
undertake shared work but I if I agree
that there's part of it might need to
find somewhere that had already been
done but as far as I'm aware we haven't
actually agreed how much would of that
would be coming back to us directly at
this stage they are following it up for
Mike Jerry it was before work already
done they didn't specify it didn't
specify it would be chair that's why I
was
question so I'll take your wife's name
is Cheryl the cost of ever it might be
the five Authority share all of the
money line
I was just be concerned if we fail to
get in as one so you'll get the answer
yeah thank you
you'll be prepared is mercifully short
got the questions faster than Bonanza
moving um just following on the next
paragraph down from what we've just been
talking about the two hundred thousand
pounds award was made for enabling works
being in the building industry I know
enabling works just covers a multitude
of sins can you give us a little bit
more clarity on what the enabling works
is actually all that two hundred
thousand pounds is being spent on yes
so the bid was made to a lot of public
estate to do work in relation to our
asset plans which members will have had
cited previously so in relation to buy
them work for example none of that money
is actually being said spent at this
stage so there's no so we haven't
actually spent the money at this point
in time but we're holding it and we'll
have to demonstrate that we're using it
for the purposes for which it was before
before we can actually utilize so that
was actually what was the actual bid for
the expenditure name because if planning
has already been done is that something
that we're looking at paying later date
for and these sort of a bad loan payment
that have come out of this so I think
the why the grant bid was worth it
wasn't it was reasonably nonspecific so
I don't think it was absolutely for
specific pieces of work but it was for
Germany to enable that site to be
brought back into use because that's the
purpose of that for our program is to
enable the vendor site serving under
utilized to be bought back into you so
it was to enable those sites to be
developed
but the actual specific items of
expenditure that was do you use for I
don't think were set out in detail but I
can again take that away and come back
to slightly more detail if that's
helpful
thank you last thing on that one name is
their autonomy calling to spend on their
gone and so again I don't think there's
a firm time limit the monies were only
awarded and watching physically order to
us and right at the back end its
financial year and we have been in
conversation with the government
ordering for day and they are reasonably
flexible of us to buy yeah how when we
use the monies so then if there's no
firm time limits but potentially if we
use if we didn't use the money within a
reasonable amount of time it's
potentially they could ask for it back
so it's not as though we can use it for
what it father purposes we have to keep
it in an earmark reserve and if we don't
if we don't spend it and are able to
demonstrate what we spend it up on when
they ask then we it's possible we could
have to return it but at the moment we
over told those monies and we're
planning to use them suggests it would
probably be useful to know if there is a
time limit on that from the point of
your investment board I would degree of
it I've got okay I think the central
government themselves have been quite
they've about the theatric times and
conditions because we is obviously
helpful to us to know what terms and
conditions associated with particular
grants but the government hasn't been
that specific in terms of that they've
been sort of as I say reasonably
flexible about how those monies could be
used so we can push for more detail from
them but at the moment we haven't quite
interpretation they're going to be
back in time see Thank You peg 15 second
paragraph at the bottom and there are
still some supports we have the service
we have a 2003 Microsoft service and
they're no longer supported by the
butter software people which means if
there are any vulnerable because that I
play what they can't get past because
patches are not provided as that is as
other key I can that's been holding us
back from the connecting comprise of the
public sector network right now
work is on hand at the moment of trying
to migrate any items that are on the
2003 service to more compliance service
which will then be able to move into the
fab environment but my understanding
what I'm gonna it's being delayed till
after the final account sir not gave the
way of the final encounters experience
what systems are running a through those
servers at lonely I'm just concerned
about risk
well the systems are being migrated
inside I don't think we've got another
exactly still happily done one moment we
take a founder
children I've got a couple of questions
that I did put through to map Beverly
because he didn't get them till last
minute I believe he actually send them
through to Natalie this afternoon I mean
really
yeah unfortunately yeah I'm funny and
these right before I left the office so
I haven't had a chance to look through
them in detail and having had a quick
glance I don't think any of them pertain
specifically so items are the agenda
tonight so I'm just a psych respond
outside of the meeting the original
response to those questions could could
we just sorry chairman with your
indulgence could we just voice these
questions because I think they are
relevant to what we should be actually
aware of and be asking in one in
particular with the cash machines but
not tonight and 20 of the reports on the
agenda for tonight no no I mean that
could be brought forward as a future
meeting but I would say that it's
probably touched on some outside at this
meeting yeah so Jim the only thing now I
have a question on that some of this is
time orientated and if we wait another
two months for another meeting at least
if we are aware that the questions are
out there and maybe you could come back
to us in the meantime we could have the
questions and the answers sent out to
the Audit Committee yeah so I'm happy to
send the response to the questions out
to the audience if you're happy for me
to share them public the language will
not pop in my building within the design
of the Audit Committee yeah but if it's
not on par part of the agenda for
tonight which is really outside
providing we get the answers you know
within a reasonably short period of time
yeah yeah well we'll try and second item
with the minutes Oliveira in no time
the main thing that it's been brought to
my knowledge with obviously we will know
about the cash collection machines have
been taken out of the four years in the
Council
the reason being why I brought this up
is I think this is actually increase the
risk to the council because the people
who actually use them a lot of people
who normally have cash in their pocket
there are people who maybe don't have
hearts elsewhere they just fashion
operators and if we then have taken that
away without giving them any other means
to be able to pay ie through the post
office or bank
wherever banks might be then we have
increased our risk while taking the mill
now I'm no winning at this was
questioned I was told that they were
taken out the GDD artists so I run a few
and I was told that the reason being why
these were taken down because of gdpr
but the thing that I can't get my head
around is that if someone makes a
payment into one of these machines
originally the data that we were
collecting would be their name their
account the amount they pay and when
they paid now that doesn't change I
understand
I hear what you're saying man is down
but we do have an answer for now me she
will give you the answers to this and
all of us the art service within the
next couple of weeks you know it is in
the carpus agenda so you know everybody
perhaps you can be satisfied that we
will get an answer to these message the
kind of flagging up because yeah
something that I think we have increased
our risk as a council well we've got it
flat and we will get the answers to this
with it within the next capture of one
in June so there are any other questions
on the agenda on this item eight
Oh 9:15 the last paragraph the Pearson
accreditation is that very serious and
does it have any real effect on what we
did that moment I think meant that
anyways well it can be can be quite
serious to perspective the presentation
people decided we cannot we're not from
prior and the DWP decided because we're
not applying it can restrict our
operations in trophies and benefits we
have a secure contact with the DWP and
members of staff over carry our benefit
assessments can go into the DWP database
and see what benefits people who have
very sensitive information and the risk
is that we would have to do it almost by
post rather than online but we are at
the moment mostly completed a
questionnaire by the for the VWP which
has been completed in conjunction with
those you serve which is providing them
technical details about the way the
infrastructure works we should hopefully
put the DWP at rest of it and show it
obviously to get them to come to get the
runs would be done you so is it online
form and using we've been told that we
should be compliant but obviously it
will have to keep an eye on that
dimensional media writing at that time
for them yeah we've been assured that we
had to me that we wouldn't be compliant
by energy like that we have a submit an
application and if I remember certainly
the research we've got last time we
really got to put a blast of about 18
months so then to respond but we should
be the message to try and
thank you any further questions now so
the recommendation is to recommend that
the statement